امريكا وكندا واوروبا تعلن الحرب على تيك
توك والصين ترد ناقصكم ثقه في النفس
والتفاصيل الكامله لاتهام فتاه فرنسيه
لاشرف حكيمي بالاغتصاب ومقابله خاصه
لتفاعلكم مع نجم التنس الكندي فيلكس
اهلا فيكم
[موسيقى]
امريكا اعلنت الحرب رسميا على تيك توك
والبيت الابيض رسميا اصدر قرار امس من
مكتب الرئيس عنوانه لا تيك توك على اجهزه
الدوله القرار يمهل الهيئات الحكوميه 30
يوم لحذف تطبيق تيك توك من اجهزه موظفيها
والانظمه الحكوميه والسبب هو المخاطر اللي
بيشكلها التطبيق المملوك لشركه بايد دانس
الصينيه على الامن القومي الامريكي
وطبعا في كلام كثير في الغرب عن سيطره
الحكومه الصينيه على الشركه المالكه
للتطبيق ومخاوف من انها تكون بتستخدمه
للتجسس وفي ديسمبر الكونغرس كان صوت على
مشروع قرار بيمنع الموظفين الفيدراليين من
استخدام تيك توك على الاجهزه الحكوميه ومن
بعد عده وزارات ولايات بشكل منفرد حضرت
تيك توك من الاجهزه المملوكه للدوله او
الاجهزه الشخصيه لموظفي الدوله اذا
بيستخدموها للعمل مو بس امريكا على فكره
المفوضيه الاوروبيه التابعه لي الاتحاد
الاوروبي اصدرت قرار مماثل بيحضر التيك
توك من اجهزه المؤسسه وموظفيها وقالت انه
هذا اجراء لحمايه البيانات وتعزيز الامن
الالكتروني وكندا كمان اخذت نفس القرار
ورئيس حكومتها قال انه قرار لازم يخلي حتى
المواطنين يفكروا في امن بياناتهم الخاصه
والبرلمان الاوروبي من ساعات اعلن نفس
الشيء
المشركه اللي هي المالكه لتيك توك واللي
من سنوات في اي صله لها بالحكومه الصينيه
وبتعتبر الموضوع بمجرد اكاذيب علقت على
القرار على اللسان المتحدث باسمها بانه
المخيم للامال وان الدول ما عدت ايش
مخاوفها من التيك توك ولا ناقشتها او
تشاورت مع الشركه الحكومه الصينيه كمان من
جانبها هي ما سكتت وهذا كان تعليقها على
اليسار
كودات حوض
تفاعلكم بالمستخدميه تيك توك ومن طرف او
حتى لنا رايي او موقف في الحرب اللي شغاله
بين الغرب والصين حول التطبيق لكن لازم
كمان ننوه لملاحظه مو احنا الوحيدين اللي
شايفينها يعني بصراحه هذه الملاحظه بتحط
علامات استفهام كبيره على الموقف الصيني
فالصين اللي بتدافع عن التطبيق وبتنفع
علاقتها فيه وبتسخر من الغرب الخائف منه
ورغم انه التطبيق تابع لشركه صينيه لكنها
حرمه مواطنيها من التطبيق وحاضرته هي
نفسها داخل البلاد وسامحه للمواطنين
يستخدموا التطبيق شبيه لكن في تعديلات
التطبيق اسمه وهو مملوك للشركه نفسها
وبختلف عن تيك توك بانه اولا مصمم بضوابط
وقيود بتحمي الشباب مثل انه بيتم الطلب من
المستخدمين اللي بتقل اعمارهم عن 14 سنه
استخدام وضع اسمه وضع المراهقين وهذا
الشيء بيخلي التطبيق متاح للاستخدام 40
دقيقه في اليوم بس بين الساعه 6:00 الصبح
هو عشره المساء علشان يلحقوا يناموا عدد
ساعات كافيه خوارزميات وكمان مختلفه عن
خوارزميات تيك توك فهي بدل ما تعرض مقاطع
فيديو راقصه وتحديات متنوعه بتعرض محتوى
ملهم علمي وتعليمي وتاريخي للصين وبتروج
للتمسك الاجتماعي والوطنيه والتطلعات
الشخصيه كمان عنده اجراءات وقائيه براقب
فيها الوقت اللي بيقضيه الشباب على المنصه
وانواع المحتوى اللي بيشهدوه يعني الصين
خايفه على ادمغه شبابها وثقافتهم والمحتوى
اللي بيشوفوا لكن في نفس الوقت بتصدر
للعالم اللي خايفه منه عادي يعني كده
نعرف المهم للحديث ممكن يعرف هذا الموضوع
اكثر واكيد يعرف هذا الموضوع اكثر معانا
من الرياض الخبير التقني عبد العزيز
الحمادي اهلا فيك معانا عبد العزيز يعني
اول شيء يخلينا نبتدي من اللي هي الاخبار
اللي جالسه العاجله اللي جالسه بتجي من
امس عن الحكومات ومنعها للتطبيق على هواتف
الموظفين الرسميين والهواتف الحكوميه وما
الى ذلك برايك هل هو يعني حركه سياسيه ولا
لا فعلا خوف مبرر
طبعا ساره هذا يعني جزء بسيط من الحرب
الالكترونيه القائمه ما بين الشرق والغرب
اليوم الحرب الجديده هي حرب تطبيقات حرب
امتلاك عدد مستخدمين حرب بيانات حرب
منتجات اكثر من انها تكون حرب عسكريه كما
كانت في السابق اليوم الصين جالسه فعليا
تهاجم الغرب بطريقه جدا
مستمره عن طريق المنتجات الصينيه اللي
نشاهدها ونشاهد انها جالسه تزيد بشكل كبير
جدا العملاق الصيني ولا التيك توك وتيك
توك في اقل من ست سنوات وصل عدد
المستخدمين في الى اكثر من مليار مستخدم
لو قارناه بعدد من المنتجات الاخرى مثل
السناب شات ولا غيره وجدنا انها في غضون
اكثر من عشر سنوات حتى ما وصلت الى 700
ولا 800 مليون مستخدم فلذلك هذا هذا
التطبيق البسيط اللي يستخدمه اكثر من 250
مليون امريكي 200 اكثر من 250 تحميل
مليون تحميل من امريكا لوحدها اكثر من 150
مليون تحميل في اوروبا لوحدها بطبيعه
الحال اكيد هذه البيانات اليوم وين وين
متاحه متاحه في الصين اذا ارادت الصين
معرفه يعني بيانات الاوروبيين والامريكان
بضغط الزر واحده عن طريق تطبيق يسمى تيك
توك بامكانها الاستحواذ عليها بطبيعه
الحال هذا هذا جزء
هذا الشيء مو نفسه ينطبق على فيسبوك على
حتى يعني على تليفوناتنا والشركات المصنعه
لتليفوناتنا
طبعا اكيد الناس تنطبق عليها بشكل كامل
اليوم اذا استخدمنا يعني امريكا تمتلك
معلومات عننا ايضا طول الوقت
صحيح ولكن يعني الصين اليوم على سبيل
المثال هي يعني تستخدم هذه في بطبيعه
الحال في معلومات استخباراتيه تستخدم في
كذا في اليوم الامريكي على سبيل المثال هي
قائمه في يعني نستطيع القول شبه حرب بارده
ما بين امريكا والصين في ذلك كل جهه تريد
الحد من المعلومات التي تستخدمها يستخدمها
الطرف الاخر عنها اليوم على سبيل المثال
امريكا جالسه تدعم الشركات الامريكيه
لايجاد بدائل لتيك توك تيك توك طبعا الحرب
ما بينها وبين الحكومه الامريكيه مو جديده
نحن نتكلم عن قرابه اربع سنوات من عام
وسجال كبير جدا ما بين الحكومه الامريكيه
وتكتك الشركات الامريكيه
الرئيس الامريكي ترامب
صحيح تماما فاليوتيوب انتجت يوتيوب شورت
انستجرام انتجت انستجرام
يعني
تحارب او تنافس بشكل كبير جدا
التطبيق الصيني تيك توك لكن بطبيعه الحال
هذه الحرب اكيد ستستمر لن تتوقف كل شركه
تحاول
السياسيه التجاريه بالدرجه الاولى اكثر من
مع استخباراتيه ما تحس هذا الشيء
طبعا اكيد هي نستطيع القول على انها
تجاريه وايضا في نفس الوقت من يملك
البيانات وهي يملك صناعه القرار اليوم
الحكومه الصينيه مثل ما ذكرتي في التقرير
ساره لديها تيك توك للخارج ولكن لديها صح
كيف نقدر نفسره
نفسره ان الحكومه الصينيه تحاول يعني
ابقاء البيانات الصينيه داخل الصين يعني
اليوم ممنوع الصينيين استخدام جوجل ممنوع
عليها باستخدام عدد من تطبيقات الامريكيه
هل هذا فقط تجاري لا اكيد تجاري وايضا
سياسي طبيعه الحال اليوم ليس فقط اليوم
على سبيل المثال عدد مستخدمين في الصين او
التحميلات في الصين تجاوزت اثنين مليار
تحميل الباي دانس فقط داخل داخل
قصدك للتطبيق الثاني مو تيك توك
لا التطبيق الثاني الباي دانس عفوا اللي
هو التطبيق اخر اسمه
دبماش هذا التطبيق مشابه لتيك توك
لتحميلاته بمئات ايوه
صحيح لذلك هذه التطبيقات الصينيه تدعمها
بشكل كبير جدا حتى تقلل من استخدام
الصينيين للتطبيقات امريكيه والحد من
مشاركه البيانات مع الحكومات الغربيه طيب
يعني اذا لما يطلعوا اليوم الصينيين
ويقولوا للامريكان والدول الاوروبيه وكندا
والاتحاد الاوروبي وكذا انه اكون انتم ايش
بكم
يعني هم كانهم بيعكسوا الكلام عن نفسه
كمان يعني رمتني بدائها وانسلت
صحيح طبعا اليوم كل واحده فعليا هي بحاجه
للاخر بطبيعه الحال ولكن اتفق مع كلامك
طيب الان بس لو تشرح سريعا عبد العزيز ايش
خطوره لما شخص او دوله تملك هذا النوع من
المعلومات
طبعا اليوم
الاستخدامنا لمعلومات مثلا على سبيل
المثال الصين لماذا تقوم بالحد من يعني
استخدام الصينيين
للتطبيقات الامريكيه هم ينظرون من منظور
انه اليوم اذا كانت معلومات الصينيين
ثلاثه مليار شخص صيني معلوماتهم موجوده في
احد
في احد
الذي احد الحكومات بطبيعه الحال سيستطيعون
التحكم
بثقافه هذا الشعب سيستطيعون التحكم
بالاعلانات سيستطيعون التحكم
كيف يفكر هذا الشعب بشكل كامل راينا مثال
قريب لي كيف تحكمت الحكومه الروسيه عن
طريق فيسبوك بالانتخابات الامريكيه في عهد
ترامب كيف استطاعت ان تميل يعني بنتائج
الانتخابات بشكل
اتهامات لم تثبت ويعني روسيا نفتها يعني
لكن بطبيعه الحال يستطيع من يملك البيانات
توجيه هذا الاستخدام بطريقه او باخرى الى
ما يريده
نهايه طبعا حتى المرشحين بيستخدموا برضه
بيشتروا بيانات المستخدمين عشان يعرفوا
كيف يتوجهوا لهم في الاعلانات وما الى ذلك
نحن بنشكرك على هذه المداخله كان معنا من
الرياض الخبير التقني عبد العزيز الحمادي
شكرا لك عبد العزيز
النجمه المغربي اشرف حكيمي لاعب فريق سان
جيرمان من ابرز الشخصيات التي تناولتها
الاخبار في العالم الساعات الماضيه وامثل
فيفا اختارته ضمن التشكيل الافضل لعام
2022 لكن الليله المفروض تكون من اسعد
ليالي تحولت لكابوس عليه وعلى محبينه اللي
انصدموا فجاه بانباء اتهام فتاه لوبي
الاغتصاب صحيفه لو باريزيان الفرنسيه كانت
اول من كشف الموضوع واللي بعدين اكدته
مصادر مقربه من التحقيقات وقالت انه فتاه
عمرها 24 سنه توجهت لمركز شرطه وقدمت بلاغ
بانه حكيمي اغتصبها في منزله وقالت الفتاه
للشرطه انه هي مو شكوى ضده لكن هي بس تريد
ان تقدم بلاغ باغتصابها لكن رغم كده ضابط
الشرطه القضائيه اللي تكلمت معاه تواصل
فورا مع النيابه العامه والنيابه العامه
ورغم عدم تقديم الفتاه شكوى لكنه وضع يده
على الق نظرا لخطوره الواقعه ولشهره
المتهم
وتم تحويل القضيه الى محكمه مونتير وهي
محكمه قريب او قرب فارس وتتبع لها المنطقه
اللي وقعت فيها الحادثه المحققين للان ما
استمعوا لاقوال الفتاه بالمناسبه لكن
تقرير لوبريزيان بنقل روايتها بانها تكلمت
مع حكيمي على انستجرام يوم 16 يناير وفي
25 فبراير ليلا راحت لعنده على بيته في
منطقه فاخره قرب باريس بسياره اوبر حكيمي
اللي طلبها وهناك الامور خرجت عن السيطره
وقبلها غصبا عنها وخلع عنا ملابسها رغم
اعتراضها واغتصبها ولكنها قدرت في الاخر
انها تزيحوا عنها وضربته برجلها وبعثت
رساله لصديقتها اللي جات واخذتها وفي عطله
نهايه الاسبوع راحت لمركز الشرطه وتقدمت
بالبلاغ
[موسيقى]
تفاعلكم مستمر معكم مشاهدينا في عرض
مقابلات خاصه مع نجوم تنس عالميين
التقيناهم على هامش بطوله دبي المقامه
الان اليوم مقابلاتنا الخاصه مع الكندي
فيليكس او جي اليسيم النجم الشاب المصنف
تاسع عالميا واللي سبقه كان السادس كمان
واليوم لعب اولى مبارياته في بطوله دبي
على فكره وكسبها تكلمنا مع فيليكس عن
انجازاته للان طموحه للمستقبل المنتظر منه
ايش كان ممكن يكون لو ما لعب تنس اترككم
مع المقابله واعود والقاكم غدا ان شاء
الله في امان الله
دبي
[موسيقى]
انمي
فوق السجانه
[موسيقى]
لكن
عندنا
لايك